-We're back with Chris Tucker.
Obviously,
you came from stand-up.
You talked about
making the leap to movies.
They were,
in the beginning, comedies.
And then you've been great
in dramas, as well.
You've worked with people --
like you said, Tarantino,
David O. Russell.
And "Air." You were so fantastic
in the air this year.
-Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It was awesome.
-And I didn't realize
the character you played,
Howard White...
-Yeah.
-...he wasn't originally
going to be in the script.
-No. No.
What happened was Ben Affleck
went down to talk
with Michael Jordan to get
his blessings pretty much,
and say, "If you don't
want me to do this movie,
I won't do it."
Michael said, "I don't care.
Just, if you're gonna do
a movie about Nike,
you've got to have
Howard White in there
because Howard White
was my connection to Nike."
And then he tried -- he wanted
to find somebody
to play Howard White,
and he always said
he wanted to work with me.
By passing --
We would pass each other.
And we were looking
for something, my team.
And Ben came to us, and he said,
"It's not a big part,
but you can do
whatever you want to do."
So I said, "Wait a minute.
I know Howard White."
So I called my --
He's my friend.
I called Howard. He said, "Yeah,
I heard about this movie."
And he took me
through his whole life,
you know, back
to high-school teachers,
gym teachers, and principals
and all this stuff.
So I just got
all this information,
and I pretty much wrote
my own part in the movie.
Like, six scenes.
I wrote every word in the movie,
my parts, and made it work.
It was already a great script,
and I just made myself
work in there, so, yeah.
-I mean,
what a great call by Affleck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Oh, yeah.
-I mean,
for Affleck to cast you,
not realizing you know
the guy you're gonna play
and then getting
free script writing.
-Yeah.
That's right. That's right.
-He's a very, very smart man.
-He's a smart man, yeah.
-I also know that one
of the reasons you knew Howard
is he was very helpful for you
over the years.
He would donate stuff
to your charity auction.
-Every year. It's crazy.
That's why I say
that was a godsent role.
Because every year
I would call him
for my foundation
golf tournament.
We had the
Chris Tucker Foundation,
and we raised money to do
underprivileged kids
scholarships
and homeless ministry
with our church.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We do everything.
So if you do good,
a movie role might come to you.
A blessing will come to you.
Because I called him every year.
And we kept in touch.
And I called him.
He said, "You want some more
shirts or something?"
I said, "No."
He didn't say that.
But I was like, "No, man.
They're doing this movie,
and you in it.
And they want me to play you."
He was like, "What?"
Then he took me down
this whole road.
But, you know,
Viola Davis is in the movie.
Chris Messina. Marlon Wayans.
Jason Bateman.
Ben Affleck and Matt.
But I was scared
with Viola Davis
because Viola Davis
is a trained actor.
She studied at Juilliard.
-Yes.
-So the first scene, I was kind
of scared and I blacked out.
I thought I --
I'm serious.
I thought I was in
the movie "The Help."
[ Laughter ]
I looked her dead in the eyes
and said, "You is kind...
you is smart...
and you is important."
She said, "Chris,
what is wrong with you?!
This is not the movie
'The Help'!
-Yeah.
-Come on, now. Hurry up.
Get yourself together!"
-Unusable take.
-Yeah. "You're not in that
movie. This is 'Air.'
I got another movie
I gotta go do.
You the one who wait every five
years for your new movie."
[ Laughter ]
-Man, it must be so exciting
to be about to get back
on the stage this weekend
in New York City.
Do you have
any backstage nerves
or is it just excitement
about getting out there
in front of people?
-Yeah, you get it,
but you learn how to control
your nerves, you know?
And that's the best thing about
it because you master it.
Because every night, you know
it's a different audience,
different vibe,
and you just master it
and you say,
you know,
when you get out there,
the audience love you already.
All you got to do is go out
there, relax, and have fun.
So that's what I do.
And the audience is great.
It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When you're on the road,
I'm sure there's still
new material occurring to you.
Do you get excited
when you come up with something
where you're like, "Oh, I think
I might have a new bit here"?
-Yeah, like, you know,
it's a muscle, man.
Once you get it going,
it don't stop, you know?
You can make anything funny
once you --
if you got that that gift, man.
And, yeah, I love it because
every day is something,
and you add it onto something,
and it's in the moment.
It's live. It's like
being at the Super Bowl
and watching it on TV.
-Yeah.
-In the moment and live
is just --
It's awesome
because the audience --
Somebody coming in late,
they might say something,
and then there you go,
off on a whole nother thing.
-Are you then happy a little bit
when someone comes in late?
So you have material?
-Sometimes.
You know, sometimes
I'd rather just do the show,
but, you know,
when something happens,
it just brings the best
out of me, I guess, you know?
-I think people also love
that moment where they're like,
"oh, I'm seeing a thing now
that nobody else gets to see."
-Yeah. Oh, yeah. Nothing
like it. Nothing like it.
-I know a lot of people
ask me all the time --
Will there be a "Rush Hour 4"?
Is this something that people
can expect an answer for
if they buy a ticket
to see you on stage?
-Yeah, I tell everybody,
you know, if you want to know
if I'm doing another
"Rush Hour 4" or "Friday,"
you got to come
to the Beacon Theatre.
Saturday night,
because Friday night's sold out.
-Friday is sold out.
-Come on out.
I think we got a few tickets
Saturday night.
-All on my tour. You can catch
me anywhere around the world.
St. Louis. Chicago.
I'm going all over.
Indianapolis, We're everywhere.
-Well, look.
Go check it out, you guys.
It is --
There it is right there.
The Legend Tour 2023.
Chris Tucker, everybody.
For tour information,
go to ChrisTucker.com.
We'll be right back
with Paul Dano.